yeah man I'm first of all want to
apologize for Brendan's voice and the
fact that he's gonna be coughing a lot
no come to the flow he succumbed to the
pill I have not you've been sick of the
hard flu you've been sick as [ __ ] but
I'm proud of you because you went you
went all four days without a peep in
Portland and you put up you put your
shows up without any complaints but you
had the flu
let's get you have what I had yeah what
I had while your voice is going you're
coughing you have the croup cough and so
as my wife says my daughter there my
whole household
except for my son they're all [ __ ]
like mine started just in my head like
my body was aching and then I got over
that yeah and then it moved it was like
oh you think you're done yeah let's move
on down throat and my throat was certain
like a mother shocker and then it was
like let's go upstairs well no let's
keep going lower let's go yeah yeah he's
trying it - that hardly kill you
cuz for me the flu hit me ten days solid
broke out into a viral rash and you know
what happened when this arises it's got
more sense here's the tail still not
100% doesn't matter now it completely
said I'm not gonna touch your nose I'm
not gonna touch your nose but I'm gonna
go deep into your chest
yeah I guess deep in my nose is young
and in you're gonna and then no but hey
day eight let's let date let's get crazy
so that he develops bronchitis but also
when he's coughing let's make sure it
really hurts his head and then and then
and then let's have a full-blown skin
attack so he looks like a leper ya don't
have the skin attack so I definitely get
the flu I get the flu from you probably
Thursday morning I welcome had to go to
Portland I thought um I have to cancel
yeah I was so sad on the plane I was
like holy I taking that picture of it I
might die on my way that's a terrible
thing and then I to show that night did
you take medicine yeah medicine but you
know can he do a quo that [ __ ] works
mute musics yeah and then some
antibiotics do you know what stayed on
it do you know for you don't you know J
cuz since I was in Portland you know J
was there and Buster was there to get
opposed to drove down from Seattle but
you know Jay wants to [ __ ] see the
town he was to walk around talk to
myself doesn't say just visit every type
before morning
want to go over there because sure him
down yeah yeah yeah and uh I was I
started to feel better than what would
so out there I didn't know this adidas
had headquarters so then when their
headquarters out there and then Nikes
has their headquarters out there and you
have to be on the list to get in there
have you have you heard of this chin no
you sort of this you have to be out like
an employee someone has to get you on
the list I can't just walk up yeah it's
kind of a beast to get in there do you
do you know that when in like the 1700s
even the eighteen hundred's before the
concept of germ theory now the German
you know germ theory so germ theory was
like when they started to figure out
when Leeuwenhoek this guy invented the
microscope and he started spitting he
would spit he take his breath smelled
really bad in the morning and this
[ __ ] guy would spit on the slide and
look through he developed microscopes
and the way you did is you have to grind
glass you have to grind the glass a
certain way I guess to magnify it and so
he would spit on the glass and look and
he noticed that his spit had all these
[ __ ] moving little organisms then he
would brush his teeth he would clean his
mouth out with all different ways of
doing it and then spit and there weren't
those little and so he's like holy [ __ ]
man they're like germs in my mouth
long story short then when people like
in World War two you if you got a cut
and if you got a cut you basically you
were or they would and if you look at
the Civil War and and there are a lot of
pictures you can bring them up you don't
have to but there are just there are
literally piles of legs and arms and it
would be carpenters who would just saw
your [ __ ] arm off because do it can't
because you knew it would get gangrene
because we didn't have a way to clean
the wound and we didn't have antibiotics
oh and don't get a flu back then dead
hard percent because that so I talked to
the doctor she goes she goes you you
have bronchitis I go so if I left that
she goes why are you probably pneumonia
and I go and then what I didn't have she
goes you would that's why people would
die of the flu you get them pneumonia
and then just die you can't breathe and
die so [ __ ] thank you antibiotics do
you know how antibiotics were like where
Fleming who is this like scientist he
had a cold and and one of the Petri that
he hadn't cleaned the petri dishes out
and one of the petri dishes had mold on
it
and he his his nose he like [ __ ] that
crazy his
nose dripped into one of the petri
dishes by accident he's like it's not
because I'll clean that later comes back
and he notices that where the mold is
the his snot like where the mole is the
snot was basically the bacteria was dead
so the mold killed the bacteria he's
like what the [ __ ] is going on and
that's how he invented penicillin that's
where I invented the derivative
penicillin is like so so certain molds
kill bacteria and that's that was the
beginning of getting antibiotics which
has all of us about a hundred percent
all four of us in this room are here
because of antibiotics we're sure we
weren't there we'd be [ __ ] dead but oh
yeah it was gonna say so back in the day
they would they're they called it the
humors they basically your body would be
out of balance so there were there are
things that you had to have exercise
sleep good evacuations where you had to
poo they would test your poo and see how
you're doing good food and then what was
the fifth one I don't know man a Hashem
like if you were too passionate who
would the doctors with it was all about
balance and they'd be a whole lot of the
day dude
are you as your heart are you too
passionate about something we got to
bring it into balance so that's what a
doctor would check you for and but you
know then you get [ __ ] function which
is tuberculosis it's just it's so
annoying you're the dot it's such a
hassle I hear you're the doctor on
Wednesday it's just such a [ __ ] I how
it is he lap that he lap that's here but
you know if you have to have x-rays and
stuff they can't do that yes you had a
doctor he goes sure haven't bright too
much to do too much work you sent me the
funniest hashtags it's too much work
don't hit on Joanna yeah it's way too
much work together the doctor man make
it easier this yeah go cuz you've been
sick for about seven years now yes seven
years though fact about poor Lina of the
most strip clubs per square mile
yes it does do you know that and did you
know that a lot of those strip clubs
have girls that have dicks
well no but a lot of those girls there
there's no Sun there so and an exercise
gotta be in the wires you know a lot of
white why Anna's optic body like a body
from the 70s and there's nothing wrong
with that
I guess there's so many there back in
the day there's so many workers at the
ports and stuff yeah a lot of tattoos a
lot of tattoos a lot of beards yeah
coffee's a uniform is a Portland uniform
yeah even though I can't drink coffee
and I love coffee
I can't have coffee yeah and then uh
some of the best Thai food in the world
which are surprising Portland yeah but
it's ranked yeah good food that's a good
club too great club helium right yeah I
like it a lot really good club did it
rain was a cult not bad NASA was
freezing huh
Nashville I was chipping ice off from a
car I didn't really get snow Thursday to
go look it's gonna snow tomorrow schools
are cancelled an we're gonna cancel your
second show I go what are you talking
about of course you're not listen I
understand nobody will come out it
starts snowing by noon I cut my own hair
cuz I'm an [ __ ]
yeah chopping my own hair before doing
this I know I'm like I gotta get that
the guy I got a new sense I know a lot
about hair cutting just do it Bry and
once you start you can't stop cuz you
got to even [ __ ] out the I do think he's
it up yeah then I look at my back in my
head and I got a [ __ ] doll up in the
back of my head am I am I basically I
look like a [ __ ] like that snow
didn't get you here and now I'm now I'm
driving around in the snow looking for a
barbershop they close to everybody like
I can't cut air in this inch of snow
who's just like chase rollers cause I
see I see his [ __ ] and cold oh it was 67
or 65 that's fair then it went down to
12
I don't know gets a cold night either
it's a south as Tennessee you die out
there no Nashville besides Vegas it
might have beat Vegas no more in place
for a bachelorette party crazy
100 percent it's all girls some are
overdue as [ __ ] Ville u.s. 8 well I'll
tell you this you see a lot of groups of
girls with penis like you know penis
squirt guns and some of them are dressed
in but they're also have literally size
that I like anal I'm not kidding then
about supplies what about the the y'all
you see all the girls on the bike a word
on the the booze cruise they're all
drinking like crazy and also then a
bunch of girls came in and they were
wearing they were in they were dressed
like furries all of them oh wow all of
them were dressed like furries I was
like okay I guess this is what you guys
do on your
bachelorette party good food out there
yeah or not really not really
then there's good food in Nashville I
know they've that though that the
chicken out there forget what's called
yeah I didn't do it I didn't do it I had
ten boudu doughnuts
you ate ten probably the was there for
four days yeah it's like three days so
they're so [ __ ] good no chin where
the [ __ ] are my doughnuts I wanted a way
to make sure you wanted him like now
after you came back from Boston I don't
know if you're dieting or not do you
have him
not everyone see how you guys broke
Brad's heart I know I'm not eating wheat
right now my psoriasis aw damn um but I
would know since I've been sick like
that stop it coffee
Kido all these the vitamins I've been
taking I'd stop everything dude
revamp it exactly and you know for me
I'm a [ __ ] I'm a whiskey I'm a
gentleman now I don't know if you guys
know I'm an older gentleman so I drink
whiskey and of course because I'm an
[ __ ] I have to drink the most
expensive and I've discovered a new
whiskey called Blanton's I think
Blanton's I think whiskey not only does
it not do me any favours I think it
exacerbates my psoriasis as well as
sugar it does whiskey yeah yeah so it
[ __ ] me up yeah yeah so no more whiskey
for Brian you need a drink though as an
older gentleman few minds campari still
I like that I like an expensive bourbon
I'll be honest
I like a smooth expensive bourbon just
not there yet no you got a bday coming
up I gotta be there 5151 that hurts me
51 I was just difficulty one yeah I was
just 15 oh I know wasn't I
well I mean last year yeah I know but it
doesn't seem like a year no time is
going fast for us buddy it really is
what should we do on your beat not be
sick so much um I think we should go to
Prada and buy me a couple of boots brah
yeah I said it
and then well what do I need I got an
iPad pro oh it's it's an iPad um I don't
know how to use technical - dinner
dinner
I like dinner I like laughing I like
eating well I'll drink too much wine
feel like [ __ ] the next day some fresh
my face super swollen for the next day
that's what we'll do at 51
we'll get my face super Swan I'll tell
you something else about 50 I don't know
if this happens use you're an athlete
what I
wake up like I did slept nine hours when
I wake up a solid set of sleeve oh yeah
because the night before I slept for so
slept nine and then I got up and I tried
to walk and I couldn't my feet need to
warm up a need to warm the oh they won't
work they sure won't they get super
stiff so I've got a warm feet up so you
get in bed and they come out I'm wigging
out yeah I got a wiggle them out I don't
know that yeah yeah I stand up in my
hand my Achilles heel is like hahaha
what excuse me
we are old meat sir and then I gotta
move my even my feet don't bend what
yeah
so you so if a robbery came this can
take a little bit us what exactly I
thought I thought somebody's attacked my
kids right now um you gotta warm up l
wouldn't feet L wouldn't you know I've
got a wit
yeah I got wood for feet I got clogs on
you gotta wait till I until I break the
wood in I don't how many problems yeah
like that why does that happen
[ __ ] I don't know amen maybe she killin
HGH now you're talkin and really
exacerbates something else you didn't
live I'm gonna do that now because I'm
afraid of that it accelerates cell
division so if you have to sell
everything yeah hey here we go I'll do
testosterone though in that HGH no test
test I'll do tests eventually when I
feel like my dick when my dick stops
being able to carve a diamond when my
[ __ ] stops being able to cut glass
that's not clothes cuz I got a dick on
me and I'm my dick is ten-hut
he reaches for the sky at 50 I'll [ __ ]
all day all out [ __ ] everybody cuz I'm a
dirtbag yeah I know and my dick when my
dick is when I feel like my dick when I
got a lazy boner when he starts getting
lazy go soft in the middle then I'm then
it's go time he it's weak in the yellow
right now I got energy for days I don't
know dude I was I was laughing on the
plane I was reading Genesis book again
sick in the head with the Amy Schumer
interview and he's talking about how in
her her SATs or like people just assume
she's like to speak [ __ ] she's with a
lot of guys she's like no not at all
it's just you know I'm I'm I always have
a boyfriend I think I have long-term
relationships I talk about my experience
of them she was
and sometimes in between boyfriends I'll
hook up with like one guy she's like
maybe one every like six years but I
just used those experience about the
stories yeah and yeah and then he goes
oh yeah do you have any good stories for
me and she goes yeah this morning I had
the biggest dick I've ever seen Jesus
and she goes he had the biggest dick
I've have ever ever seen he was this
hockey player I guess and the only
reason she went on a date with him is
because her sister was a fan she want to
be cool for her sister she's like he was
hot but like with two hot
she was so we go to dinner go to drinks
and then I was getting ready leave he's
like Oh wanna come up if he wasn't you
know next thing leads to another she was
next thing I know he takes his thing out
but just nonchalant she goes and it was
the biggest thing I've ever seen in my
life she was at she was at the hype
myself up she goes it's kind of like
seeing a unicorn from the first time she
goes like everyone wants to see one you
hear about it when you see one face to
face and you realize oh holy [ __ ] this
is a horse with a weapon she goes she
was I choose I had to do it you know
I've heard so many everyone says how
great it is big big stuff like that she
goes and it just was not happening it
was physically impossible and she goes I
asked Mike is this a prom to you like a
lot of the time he's like sometimes and
she's like well it ain't happening
make it happen she said I've always
gotten leftovers in the fridge at home
I'll go home and just to [ __ ] go to
sleep man this ain't happening to me I
know it's been the fattest taking him
that's a giant dong right yeah I would I
would wear very tight white pants all
the time and I would tie I would tie off
like at the bottom a sub inches so
people keep saying selfies like the game
there was a girl I liked in New York and
she would always invite me I had never
gotten I never closed the deal never and
she would smoke too much weed she was so
hot I met her in the park and she would
invite me to gay bars every single time
and I want a gay bar her best friend was
gay any died of AIDS and so she was
mourning him or some weird thing I don't
know she told me like you know but she
was always we go to gay bars it be just
Kay dudes
muscular handsome dudes and I went to
one thing where these [ __ ] muscular
dudes were dancing on
stage and they were both wearing loose
sweatpants oh yeah and they have a
biggest dick this one guy had the
biggest weren't wearing undies
yeah I've seen a dick his arm Outland
the hog fly I looked at her I go that's
the biggest dick I've ever seen she goes
yeah that guy that guy's a real hit here
and he was this white dude he might have
been Puerto Rican handsome ripped out of
his mind
wait I quietly put a wrench in bro I
don't know he was like I'm gonna say
white for the story but he was white for
the story yeah and super blond hair a
long blonde ponytail blue blue eyes he
was a white Walker look like a white
Walker and he was now by now and he was
I've never seen a dick like that in my
life I just couldn't stop staring at it
she was like pretty fascinating high go
no no I'm just I'm looking at he seems
to be a real dancer she goes yeah but
it's good enough memorizing leave it
yeah mesmerized and memory yeah but it
isn't it's kind of weird
so Amy Schumer discredited the best the
unicorn man now you know guys this is a
horse with a weapon on his head holy
[ __ ] that's a hell of putting games some
girls say that but then my buddy has the
biggest dick on the planet and there are
a lot of girls are just getting hung up
on that [ __ ]
well this well for sure some down for ya
yeah I've been to a gay club - I
remember my first went down he has
dating this girl and she wanted I ended
up at two gay bars with me yeah she'd
always invite me out to him they love
you but it's weird little how far you go
for a hot chick yeah I figured of course
I'll figure this that whatever I guess
Hobbit train run I mean if that's what
you want yeah blood lineup with cocky
later
this strange man sometimes being a big
dick sometimes you watch your porno and
the guys think is so big where the blood
flow just there's not enough blood and
the human body with pens over he's got
an elbow it's got an elbow so it's just
like yeah it's like heavy bad has like a
that's like wrinkles in it any hole is
looking down yep yep his Bo that will
hurt me too when he comes he hits the
ground immediately right in front of
this ancient crane almost but then it's
all wrinkly at the bottom with a big old
doorknob and he just sleepy and the
girls like walk hop I don't know I
appreciate that your cooks like trying
to figure this puzzle lap
it's almost always a black guy with
giant thighs yeah she's a micron she's
kneeling in the or it's a really skinny
white guy with just a [ __ ] iguana
stick on ya guy who's never done a squat
in his life genious legs skinny
without [ __ ] Python straight up but
it's so bad skin
yeah bats terrible you know tear yeah
horrible teeth yep with brace horrible
actor yep and he's in sneakers as a
shitty loose off his ankles are so
skinny thoughts are all baggy but it's
so stranger to me how the dick doesn't
go straight huh it has like that hump
it's gravity gravity takes that doorknob
head and brings it right down yeah it's
like if you have a ruler you know you
keep dishing out the shitty dicks that
goes straight up and they just bend like
a Chiquita banana and then it's like hey
man that thing pokes huh all he's saying
it's like like Oh telescope yeah I knew
a good this girl would dated this guy I
knew handsome handsome guy and the girls
always liked him and she goes yeah but
his dick is really thin and and long and
long and it pokes you won't feel good
like a pencil yeah I never looked at him
the same no hell no no I was like he
also used to tell stories the usually
that were stories he heard from other
people like my friend oh I didn't have a
real personality told the story and my
friend was like that was my story that I
told him that's already forgotten now
he's adopting it there's a fighter like
that he'd tell us all these classic
stories but really before the internet
and Twitter and all that got big and
we'd hear all these stories like Connie
must be such a badass yeah we found out
he's stealing stories from this classic
fighter Rogan and I when we first
started doing a podcast probably six
seven years ago where he and I would say
things that we thought were true and
then people would google him and it
turned out they weren't true
like you know you before Google my bro
science you walked around with bro
science walking around with you know bro
facts all the time I was like um yeah
well I mean yeah you have a fact checker
all the time like I walked around
thinking that pre-cum has like you can
get Tony pregnant with pre-cum
apparently no apparently it doesn't have
sperm are you sure yeah
unless apparently you have you had you
ejaculated earlier and then sometimes it
can take the sperm that was sitting
there but that and why
50 years old are you concerned about
this no I'm just saying as a kid I when
I got sex education in high school the
the guy said that that was a case he
goes you can you can have sex with
somebody and if you even though you
haven't come that your pre-cum can get
their pregnant pregnant maybe it's still
trust I think it's true what's the
medical term for pre-cum I just
cooperate we come
I think freaking will work pre
ejaculation pre-ejaculate yeah that's
what it is pregnancy if I become
friendly with a majority of
pre-ejaculate fluid had dead or no sperm
at all it is possible for small amounts
Vern to exit your reproductive system
and makes way into the pre-cum or
projected can you get pregnant with
freak um pretty calm or can you get
pregnant without penetration or can you
get there are just some of the questions
okay pre-cum is more accurately known as
pre-ejaculate fluid this is a bodily
fluid that is released from the penis
during intercourse more importantly men
do not have any control over it early
understandings of precut once where that
sperm is expected to be part of the
fluid further investigation will reveal
to the majority of pre-ejaculate fluid
had dead or no sperm at all it is
possible bah-bah-bah can you get
pregnant the common answer is no however
women around the world have become
pregnant from pretty guy like mine
unless we cannot rule out the boss I
like my chances
these are rare cases where a living
sperm can be present in the pre con so
you're right B well we right because
that's what they tell you when you're on
school yeah cuz they just don't they
want you to be scared of everything
associated with sex
they sure do they sure do when I wonder
how they teach kids these days I marry
ours was like the whole class fourth of
fifth grade got together and all the
teachers were there and then there'd
like at they like bring up those weird
diagrams you know
and then we'd ask questions now then you
always try to make your friends laugh
like you know do we know any other names
for erection I'd like boner boner still
funny
boners gross I have a boner how did they
teach you Brian did they was a hands-on
the teacher just a live sex shows mostly
you don't want to learn from porno No
but that's where most kids learn right I
remember the first porn I saw was in
eighth grade maybe even seventh grade
and when I was watching the guy go down
on the girl I was like oh my [ __ ] god
that looks disgusting yeah oh and these
are 70 porn bushes yeah and I watched it
with a bunch of girls and guys we'd all
be like oh my god really yeah the guy
was just hung in there there's always
wind you'd watch with your buddy like
your buddy to find your dad his dad's
porn yeah so hard you'd be like man that
you can I leave IDEs like we're about
the bus oh my god I leave you guys we're
gonna split really so I can jack off
this right now because I'm gonna
I can't wait it yeah I gotta get out of
here I know we have plans I'm gonna go
jack off six times I don't think people
understand what it's like to be a young
dude the whole thing is like it's like a
[ __ ] rock why [ __ ] it's overwhelming
it's yeah you don't know like I don't
really have a sense why are we all what
like yours always weird as they group my
friends just watch that we're all just
Ross my brothers don't say there was
always a dude that would get a boner
like I know we'd wake this day I'm in
summer camp I had to go where to camp
cause my family's [ __ ] overseas and
that goes and you'd sleep in a giant
you'd sleep in this giant [ __ ] and we
would like there's a bunch of kids yeah
and what you do is you'd like you know
you pants some of you'd like pull their
sheets off and there was a dude and and
or we go
what have we all got him started dancing
we weren't supposed to we all start
going to dancing cuz you smoke when you
just put lights are out you're supposed
to be laying yeah so go well yeah he put
some you know we started dancing and we
the councillor come we jump in meanwhile
I start dancing and one of our friends I
think the name is Donnie
he's got a straight-up hard-on hey hey
what the [ __ ] it's like honey you put
your good luck the [ __ ] it's like who
let a snake in here like we're all yeah
we're all screaming he's like what like
you a didn't know and he would do it
every time we did like you ever you have
a heart on it there's some kids who are
curious about the boner they just don't
care I was like don't you hide it don't
hang a
me with a hard-on dude was there
anything worse when you were like six or
seventh grade you get a rock-hard bone
and you have to tuck it up into your
jeans during class yes
oh my krisily at one time had a I think
he's talking to somebody and he had a
half a boner and the thing about how
inappropriate this is we're gonna do the
10 minute podcast and I just see this
like I see his nose yeah he peeking
around a corner I see his nose and then
I see this heavy half dick like the
heavy l know half mast and he's got a
piece on yeah and I'm like dude and he's
moving is what I go you don't [ __ ]
come near me with a hard that get that
[ __ ] thing she's right now nothing
was lazy go yes no no it was kept gosh
so ridiculous man what do you guys do
this weekend - yeah we have no actually
was looking I got a another apartment no
really I sign a lease on another partner
we're at it's in downtown Los Angeles no
damn downtown generally Boulder City
right now just a few blocks from here
and you decide to move further away
downtown so I didn't sign the lease but
I did all the paperwork and I'm gonna go
and sign it soon like within this week
so same [ __ ] yeah cool yeah downtown uh
pop in place living alone living on oh
wow are you excited about it I'm super
excited yeah yeah well nobody can see
what you're doing with the bodies
because right now you live with
roommates I had roommates during the
transition from my last job to this one
are they bummed out that you're leaving
or they're pretty [ __ ] stoked it or
not living with a serial killer hobby
they would actually prefer me to stay
there though I bet yeah that's cool
the downtown Papa man downtown's a good
place in my loft downtown yeah me too I
mean it's changed when you have to [ __ ]
when you had to shoot downtown you would
always be like this is gonna suck rats
and just like it was awful listed worst
and now it's like I'm a still kind of by
that though which do it where no matter
well yeah like it's a set like
downtown's kind of a small my for sure
they're still rough areas down yeah but
they're also some grater yeah great it's
a booming down there get yourself a loft
down there the best thing to do that's
where I'll be shooting so I will crash
at your pass that's good I got studio
loft oh [ __ ] with humongous windows damn
darn good play all you guys if you can't
get a girl now I don't know what to tell
you seriously if I don't mount I'm just
gonna close to picture you half mass in
front of your [ __ ] loft well there's
a catch thanks Russell smart hard to
catch you're the FBI is almost a boxer
and MJ would you do that job on the mic
I want snowboarding we're at a mammoth
for day you know my day cure snow you a
good snowboarder um that was my second
time so no it's Abby's yes no bars no
something are you getting that I grew up
snowboarding you did in third grade so
you can snowboard you're a snowboard my
tail off damn used to love it so if it
you were fallen trace or we'd fallen a
lot I felt I could do it the front carve
whatever it is going backwards I fell on
my knees a couple times did you did you
have to wear a wrist no because a lot of
people break the wrist from silver so
the idea is to fall this way right yeah
but I mean sometimes you it's like fast
yeah people put the wrist out so a lot
of people were wrist bracelet basis yeah
yeah and then I just had a yoga workshop
my friend's nephew died in a motorcycle
accident and he was like this crazy yogi
this is a couple years back and then we
had a workshop down in Santa Rita we did
a hundred and eight Sun Salutations Wow
for him which sounds kind of lame but
it's a cognitive practice so he died of
go back a while back yeah so they're
bringing like the Sean O'Shay foundation
up to Santa Rita and bring yoga to
schools so like elementary schools
whatnot so that's your scene i yang gar
yoga anger that's difficult it's not a
father I'll tell you what when I was a
kid it'd be tough to teach me yoga oh
yeah good for English is impossible but
as a kid I don't want to sit there and
stretch it stuff it's like when I had to
take ballet and I was a young man
and I was very good at it I'm an amazing
ballet dancer no no no couple things I'm
I'm the best ballet dancer ever was made
to be a great ballet dancer once you
stick with it because it is I simply -
it's it's just - for lack of a better
word - effeminate
your neck has to be long you have to
reach it's a very disciplined kind of
failure but I found it so uninspired
like money I like money like a tiny bit
I've always wanted to be a tough guy
which I'm not but I've always I need the
toughest ballet dancer well it's a beaut
I just couldn't do it
I'd just be a badass - that way I want
to - yeah I hate what I enjoy but I love
salsa i love modernist i hate ballet I
hate it yeah you stood I've seen a lot
of ballet I used to do point dancing
yeah yeah well I like when I'm sure I'm
women are add a lot of you know this and
a lot of NFL teams ain't college
football teams have yoga now like we
used to have a yoga teacher named yoga
Danny I think he was crazy I liked him
though he's got a cowboy hat for sure
he's [ __ ] some people but he he would
come I think once or twice a week and
we'd all do yoga but we teachin 110 guys
for you again you get the inner-city
kids from Texas stuff yeah it's it's
tough to focus and meditate with yoga
yoga or someone fart yogi John yeah it
just I mean well we all laugh yeah yogi
John was a guy when I got here at 25
years ago 24 years ago he was my friend
was talking about yogi John and he had I
was going he was just one of those
unorthodox yogi guys who you know was
just like like my friend lost his job
and he was good he was one of those guys
great I do love the new possibilities
congratulations this is a start journey
yeah [ __ ] you bro the broke journey
that's literally what he was like right
and he had all these health secrets and
my friend was like dude this guy look
this guy he's like the way he's like
some days he'll eat just meat he's not a
vegetarian but some day she'll be a
vegan
he had this whole system that you would
yogi John's system that you would do and
training was very intense and he had a
hit of school and my friend got really
into it and then Yogi John died of what
just of he just died of life they just
found him dead it's like ah it was
probably sick of his motivational [ __ ]
just now he just he's just is too much
talking about yeah his body gave out all
that health whatever he died I was like
what and he was like sixty not he was
young yeah and it's just like you know
all right it turned out he was just
[ __ ] but he had had but like many
Yogi's he had been through a crisis like
he had been a drug addict he had been so
I think his body probably was like time
to go now you see a lot of that you see
a lot of that with those even the
Tibetan Rinpoche is the moment do some
[ __ ] they many times are they have the
wrestling or sexuality issues they're
wrestling with crisis they had anxiety
issues and and I've listened to some of
them talk about it why would you wear a
saffron robe and walk around like that
that's a hard life but because they've
we usually do you don't do that yeah you
don't you don't arrive at that through
comfort no it's awesome
yeah you hit rock bottom you know I'm
with us that's [ __ ] orange robe on and
just shave my head that's right yeah
that's right so go towards religion it's
not a religion
okay it's really to just practice though
so yeah it's good yeah to go your
teacher hua form one drugs of trying to
find enlightenment right isn't it yeah
it means to unite
so it's uniting your mind to your body
mmm it depends yoga also means the way
yoga also means yoga also is the
derivative of the intentional just the
intentional stopping of the rippling of
the mind mm-hmm according to Joseph
Campbell's different kinds of yoga yeah
yeah I've got a few yoga teachers who
you know yeah fell on hard times and
found it yeah but see I something she's
right though some go towards religion
yeah something like I'm stretching chant
yeah yeah it's it's it's for everybody I
like it I think it mattered too I wish I
just cared enough about a rod to add
into my schedule anything it's been
around that like the hot yoga he's got
going I was feel good but I would like
to do it once a week more than that I
start to hate it you know when I did my
last yoga class might my hips like I
over stretched it like I don't think too
much stretching is good for me
anyway like any you can over like you
can give your actually what they're
finding is you can actually give you
some of our threaded condition if you
over stretch because your tendons
genetically are what they are and if you
keep opening that door past what your 10
is one you can actually weaken the
tenant they've actually done Studies on
athletes who do too much stretching and
when they stretch and athletes that are
actually really flexible yeah tended get
injured more and they're less explosive
use yes more than guys who are not yeah
but y'all know your limits yeah I'd like
to it once a week I don't like find the
time I would like to do it once a week
yeah it's good for your age of motion to
I'm gonna be teaching a yoga class for
weight lifters all like focusing on
range of motion hmm
so that's cool you need it I like the
hot yoga - I only like hot you I don't
like the regular standard yoga nice and
sweaty
yeah I like to get a hot up in there and
start it's nice at the Bikram yoga
school I used to go to in New York City
the men couldn't wait to get out there
in their speedos they could just be toes
trust their speed no that's here in
Santa Monica - here's Santa Monica -
yeah and you know what not great bodies
my no I would not have the courage in
now dressed like that my joke is no
girls ever like he's got a totally Yoga
body totally flat no muscle tone with
very flexible yeah no one digs that
you'd see some dancers in there and they
had bodies you know you'd see like I
remember this black dancer was in there
and I was like and he had this um I'm
very gay and he had essentially like
sort of a half speedo on and looking his
thighs in his ass and I was like cheese
like what do you do and he was I'm a
dancer and I go okay and he go I go do
you feel like you have it's got to be
pretty intense because it's very intense
and so sometimes Yoga Yoga is the way I
treat myself this is kind of my present
desert like this is my desert like oh
okay
this is your break I mean while I was
[ __ ] dying after an hour well sweetie
some current events yeah let's just
oby know how let's talked about it when
Theo was here when you were shooting
last week but you're your pilot skin
picked up my pilot is well they're
airing my pilot in the place of the yoke
of the Goldbergs and they've never done
that
so 1980-something this is Goldberg's
1990 something
starring Bryan Callen Nia Long Tim
Meadows and Wendy McClendon is doing a
cameo in it
so it's kind of exciting they've never
done that because remember the pilot
tested higher in Justin gray categories
then the Goldbergs itself they've seen
the success of young Sheldon on CBS so
who knows
so now anywhere 24th and airs 8 o'clock
ABC and if it gets good ratings and
they'll probably that would hopefully
order it right that would be it could be
because the gold Ranger things have have
to go Birds only has one more more
season so so they need something young
Sheldon it's doing well I know when this
takes place in the 90s we all want to
see [ __ ] that happened in 90 degrees way
better late yes [ __ ] Mike Lee Jordans
all that stuff yeah right yeah Michael
Jordan USC he was a big figure in the
night oh yeah what else
UFC UFC started I mean 90s yeah bo
Jackson yeah Deion Sanders yeah yeah
yeah Mike Tyson Evander Holyfield I mean
there's so much stuff yes all about
sports you got Ninja Turtles you got New
Kids on the Block in sync
yeah they're like mm all right yeah okay
yeah Vanilla Ice MC Hammer yep Nintendo
Super Nintendo Sega Genesis Nintendo
Power glove Wow ma jam oh arcade games
you got Geoffrey Barry Burd you got that
you got those come the beginning of
those commercials Reebok pumps yeah you
got pogs super soakers Hemans Ninja
Turtles maybe a Schwarzenegger in their
heyday darkwing duck gummy bears
tailspin dude you got it down well
that's my that's my [ __ ] miss Jesus what
else you have the WWE got Hulk Hogan
Macho Man Randy Savage Razor Ramon eight
I'll do the giant mmm got nirvana
yeah grunge starting yeah yeah the
grunge movement
good times in the 90s steroids in
baseball nose mm okay uh yo Dallas
Cowboys dominating Chicago balls damn
Toni Kukoc Tonya Harding I'm very
impressed
thanks man that's amazing you're going
through the whole nineties yet starter
jackets what a starter Jack what come on
man don't make fun of me man come on man
come on give me a chance man
don't laugh so hard no come on oh [ __ ] I
know what they were yeah there pull over
Jack Bauer one of these teams on them I
know they are
oh my feet I had that Hornets one god
damn those were fresh yeah
oh I had that exact jacket did I'd wear
it to school and I didn't realize the
brain was starter and me and Jay got him
for Christmas and we worn out of Dallas
Cowboys Jay had a San Francisco 49ers
and we walked on playground all the kids
got around us seventh kid goes oh man is
it starter and I turn around with yeah
it is my first one it is my first one
is there like why Jays like god dammit
oh dude how about how about the fact
that I watched my first football games
of the season
good playoffs yeah cuz I'm an [ __ ] I
guess the Pats problem right that's
probably gonna win this I hope Jack's
villains to be honest I looked really
good the best corner in the league
Ramsey he's a balanced ER they have guy
Campbell I'm gonna say next amigos who
do you have for the Super Bowl and I was
talking football and I'm just and I
couldn't drive nulliparous I got
embarrassed I was like she can't know
that I don't know I haven't watched a
game so I go you know what she goes you
gotta say it's got to be the Pats and
she goes who else and I go I don't know
how to answer this question I go so I go
I bet it's to me it's like whoa I go I
mean if who do you have
she goes and I kept doing oh I can't
Oh cheering are you too young for the or
are you too old for these jackets now is
in this thing I did all the whole the
whole like Genco jeans yes
Juicy's Gingka jeans lady Murphy and
Arsenio Hall that's another 90s thing or
you're a bum
there's BOM and yeah there's bum I think
Bongo or something like that uh bum
equipment yeah no I got it all the color
yeah man that TV yeah but I mean yeah so
that's a now the nineties man big deal
why wouldn't if you type in 90s on their
chin if you just type in 1990s what pops
up about 99 Isis I think you owe
dude Fresh Prince of bel-air earth coal
or goes huge Saved by the Bell
Lopez look at how hot you do do you
remember how but yeah Jalen P Diddy
dated does not change he is delicious
do you remember how big of a deal was
when the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
the movie was about to drop my dad my
brother and I waited in line for two
hours no you did in two hours really we
got in there and I fell asleep
you're definitely great dad you know my
dad was a beast do you know that guy
Ernie Reyes jr. he was the same one I
need soon as they're still going on
what's up that asian kid in the movie
you probably don't remember in oh yeah I
do remember him he was part of the
shredder clan but I'm still working for
the girls he was a snitch he's a Korean
snitch no no not that guy let me see if
I could find a man how about if your ear
chol do you get laid I don't know what's
he doing now all he's doing appearances
is Urkel not this kid yeah that was him
bro snitch he worked for both parties
okay yeah parties like he worked for the
master splinter
but then he was also working with the
turtle I am so this is when he's against
the Turtles
yeah see he's a [ __ ] traitor chin
what about him now he was my hero like
the only Asian kid on TV he was on like
an 80s show where he was a son of a cop
that adopted him a white cop is he world
sidekicks
I need us don't look now he was in the
rock movie with the in the jungle not
the new one oh but he was like so when
you looked up - yeah cause he was on
like the only Asian kid on TV what
Jackie chaining me
Jaquish house an older dude when I walk
in this guy was a kid he was like these
are killing it and I got to meet him in
real life - Oh was he cool did he know I
think dude Ernie Reyes jr. yeah he's
Filipino he's Filipino Ernie Reyes jr.
go back to the eighties for me chin wow
what a great movie though the new
turtles they ain't bad either the
nineties 80s 90s sorry [ __ ] the eighties
Oh full house
does it another full house Oh
Spice Girls mm-hmm Aaliyah oh I hope do
you Mara tell me what you want what you
really well I'll tell you what I want
what I really really want
yeah melody remember you remember when
and walk me through a very black
nightclub as people were grabbing her
ass without any care about she is and
she was called [ __ ] you lo ha and the
part that the big bouncer was actually a
white guy ghost tell me what you want
what do you really want to and she just
kiss my [ __ ] ass get in the car she
pushed me in the car and the fashion is
oh oh
it's Mariah what a cutie God Will Smith
just owned the 90s didn't he yeah -
pocketed clueless on man Tupac don't
call me man all boy meets world homie
Tupac bro well I'll do Topanga she was a
smoke oh it's a bank got a lot of nights
jacking off to do that yeah you don't
have to pay me I sure don't Boy Meets
World God and bring her up oh man dude
she was actually on a Maxim cover when I
was like in college I was like holy [ __ ]
she has grown I saw her an assault on
rap battle that so that's her in the
show go back Jim yeah beautiful go to
that one on Maxim Topanga has some TIG
old bitties did she did oh she does yeah
yes they are
she's pretty right yes yes they are look
at my voice gets very low I'd like to
cry into her breasts I want to cry into
your breasts Oh
this is previous see I would've yeah
what happens like torture well for her
off see she's a big star she come on and
do other things with your oh wow if your
oral what like would see what he's doing
his real name something Jamal white
learn how big Oracle was I'm surprised
you know this Julie oh he died no no
he's 41 oh [ __ ] he tweeted out some [ __ ]
Oh Oracle glass walled up so he grew
that he grew the [ __ ] up that's a big
fella did I do that yeah say that to his
face
Bryan come get something so what he's in
LA what's he up to
I mean McKenna's what's his Wikipedia
say handsome dude it's a bummer being
that nerd though huh I'll hold on he was
in oh dude he was in Mega Shark versus
chronic asuras oh [ __ ] yeah I know that
movie damn he's just working working as
much as you can
yeah but he's also take work work Kyle
he's probably set right no I don't think
so you don't think oh I'll set you know
big family man as I said man I can
promise you he's not all the guys from
friends are saying I'll buy his resume
that he's not nice all duper's maybe
just loves to work yeah he's an actor
you don't stop acting yeah but he might
be rich as [ __ ] but just loves to work I
hope he's rich as [ __ ] but I don't think
so well don't think that's how that
works
me myself why oh he's got it he's got
six episodes there and he's he's in
bonus thing he's in Atlanta he's got
he's a working episodic TV actor you
know he shows up the y5o does his thing
SantaCon he's in CSI yeah it's my resume
you never very similarly my resume yeah
similar yeah I know all about it
I know everything about him you weren't
in super [ __ ] though like no no but I
but I lived this for many years I know
all about this what do they want before
sure yes yes you don't audition though
anymore I don't why not because I've
been on a TV show for years and because
I have a great podcast and because
love stand up and I make my living that
way I am very loud so you know I I saw a
long time ago
I saw how this ends like you saw with
fighting I saw with acting how many
great and talented people and this is
the talented guy Giulio it's also I'm
sure a great guy yeah halogen guy you
meet guys like this who've been in the
business a long time
they are you just like them immediately
you have to be doing as long as easy and
he's probably a very smart and
disciplined
smart cool all that stuff and I saw that
none of it mattered and that acting
didn't give two shits about that and
that you were all you you would be
making a million dollars one year and
then six dollars the next yes and I saw
I'm mainly also talking to my business
managers who had huge clients and
watching like did them tell me look dude
you know don't be sad I know people who
leave here in tears because they're
broke and they can't find a job and it's
a [ __ ] disaster
so I saw it I saw it I saw it I saw it
and so that made you not wanna yeah
because they went not then I heard
another thing that I fascinating Robert
Forester who you wouldn't know but he
was in Jackie Brown he was a famous
actor in the see him of 70s he got out
to Robert first who said he said your
career can be over and you don't in this
business and you don't know about it for
20 years
oh I know that guy he's in every yeah he
did a bunch of oh you know what but he's
you know Highway Patrol Rhode Island he
might be less years he went 20 years
without having any work and he said he
goes 20 years he said you can you your
career can be over in this business and
he was as painful no big as you get and
you don't know it you freak you don't
you go man it's been 20 years I guess
nobody does want me and don't and that
that dumb dawns on you then yeah where
you go ooh
because entertainments different than
fighting because you can keep going
auditions I'll see it's tough to get a
role but in fighting if you lose six
straight it's like it's over it's over
but there's no more of this yeah but
with act and you can yours without doubt
with six jobs yes you know or whatever
it is you do a commercial you're making
it you're figuring if I thought that the
other day cuz there's pilot season right
yeah it's coming up yeah I started
all of that Michael yo I summon him and
here's you doing anything pricey I don't
know that's not really my thing right
now and then I thought I went I what if
Brian's gonna be busy [ __ ] I go sure
wrong as long as I've known you
no you really haven't because I had the
gold but I have this and I have the
Goldbergs and and if I wanted to think
I'll create my own [ __ ] my own show but
right now right now if I walked into an
audition I would see the same faces that
I've seen for 20 years and they're all
great and they all work and they're all
awesome guys and I love every single one
of them and they're all talented but it
would be hey Manny I was why I remember
you I knew you when I was 28 and I see
you now we're all 50 and over and it's
like we hug each other I was like what's
up buddies here we are and we're looking
at our pages and I hear him through the
door and he does his thing and he's
[ __ ] great because he's a pro you do
not do my your Dre and one of us is
getting a call and they be all and maybe
and that call is a congrats a you're on
hold or congrats you got it oh you got
the pilot
you got the we're not even the pilot
that's a big deal I'm talking about
episodic TV yes you got this one role
and you're gonna play this you got to go
to wardrobe that's what it is that's
what it is form and from most crazies
even that if your APIs Adak you get that
that's not a game changer a game changer
that's pain let meet let's say you're
maybe you let me tell you something you
ain't making any money you're in LA now
try paying your rent hey I got one
better for you you just got a ten you
got a series a popular one on Hulu a
popular one on Amazon a popular one on
Netflix ten episodes they got you locked
in though cuz you're not do another do
other shows ten episodes cool cool how
nobody gets this but I'm gonna I'm gonna
just [ __ ] around with you I'll give you
a 40 grand per episode
yeah I'm balling now nobody does that
yeah you'll get your 12 grand in episode
nowadays and be happy but let me let me
for fantasy sake eight to twelve more
realistic right yeah yeah alright but
let's say it's I'm gonna give you 40 I'm
gonna give you a 90s money I'm gonna
give you nineties money when you're
croats really high so 400 grand
basically free time wanna grab please
take half and then away right away
because with commit
and with taxes you are so lucky if
you're seeing half I've lived this for
years now you got 200 grand awesome now
you know what rents are in this town
you're not buying a house in La get-go
no sir
sir I'm going certain you can't look at
a condo for under a million dollars No
so now you got 200 grand to pay
everything you got a family
you got a rent your rent in a nice place
is gonna be what is it forty-five
hundred minimum yeah I was gonna say six
seven grand okay good that's 60 grand
that's 70 grand just in rent now the
rest you got to pay for like all your
other [ __ ] but also our breaking you are
breaking me but also remember it's in
similar to professional sports being a
professional athlete is you really need
to slump sum of money for that that
series that you shot yes you have no
idea where the next lump sum is gonna
come in you better hold that thing and I
remember getting I was they were paying
me a lot for this couple series I did
and I was like I'm not worth this though
I'm not I would do it for I know I would
do it for a third of this because I just
want to work so why has the business not
caught up and I said that's when I was
like I gotta start doing stand-up I
gotta stop cuz I gotta start making
money doing stand-up
yeah I gotta start doing and then the
podcast I saw Rogan with the podcast
thank [ __ ] god
but actors who are just actors
especially dramatic ones oh and you're
good you were in that show awesome
you're in that movie that you know won
awards you made you made most actors in
LA are making about a hundred grand a
year so you guys if they're good maybe
50 grand I live on less that's if
they're good two very famous actor it
was a married about dating a friend of
mine famous actor really great and I
said what's like she goes it's weird cuz
before my boyfriend before made money
and I go he doesn't make money she goes
Brian we split meals what and then I
looked at the numbers and I looked at
what he did and I went of course of
course that makes sense
we split meals [ __ ] amen it's it's
always been that way forever yeah you
know and then it wasn't and now it is
again less than always were sent make
being active yeah yeah it is what it is
have a second job that's all yeah I have
three jobs true just why I'm [ __ ] ball
and mom all right wait doing that I'm
not doing day I know oh okay they by the
way Martin Luther King a man of great
moral courage we are all a man himself a
white Ripper we owe much to a man named
King this is true amazing man he really
was beat some Christian yeah
so the 90s it's bad news the lead singer
cranberries
oh she committed suicide right no most
updated thing I saw was she had bipolar
disorder and she also was in a like Chad
back issues back like last year so they
had to cancel tour schedule so I think
it's possibly overdosing she was super
like humbling oh man what a [ __ ]
bummer and she's so cute died in London
at 46
god that's a bummer 46 dude I did
Rogen's podcast yesterday and when Matt
Hughes came on was emotional I started
crying bro
on I I try to talk as I said I said I'm
on [ __ ] Rogen night and I you know
she oppa you know me I don't like yeah
I'm surprising I go I go the last thing
Matt said to me a week before that train
accident was I hope I can just all I
want to do is be able to put my own
shoes on when I'm my dad's age and held
is that his dad's like 70 and stuff and
I knew he said water than the [ __ ]
cry on I had to get it together on Rogen
then I then after I saw him like he
started to cry when he was there I
started it was it was tough dude when he
started walking I was like Jesus right
yeah man it is tall you see a guy who is
that powerful that awesome I really
didn't know him well but I at least I
worked with him for a week and I read my
favorites yeah I I had lunch with him I
long talked I was powerful man when he's
walk you know like oh my god hey could
we do that though at a major
pay-per-view do we have to do on a fight
night on Sunday night or there's a
hundred thousand few where they dude I
agree like what can we bring him to
Boston maybe I don't know if you can fly
a little where that is but but that
wasn't his hometown right she's not from
st. Louis Missouri no he's from Missouri
he's from Ohio no he's from Illinois
Illinois
yeah he's not from st. Louis got you
he's from she's not Chicago uh-uh
he's got a farm out there yeah he's from
Illinois but yeah I was emotional man
when he's we're out there does we have
to do it on that shitty fight night
though
you are so right about that yeah who's
the best what else you got chin um this
right here mark walberg this is in
mainstream news how he was paid 1.5
million dollars for that reshoot where
they had to replace Kevin Spacey with
Christopher Plummer yes for that movie
and then his co-star Michelle Williams
only got a thousand which was just per
diem so she just paid just paid whatever
she was oh here's the thing with this
here's the thing here's the problems you
can't spray this is the problem with
this yeah Mark Wahlberg's contract he's
before any of this me to move in all
that when he signed up for a movie he
got in his contract this isn't a one-man
thing a woman thing this is him being a
businessman goes listen if you're gonna
bring me back to reshoot my daily rate
is this there's no compromise if you
need me to come back this is what my
time is worth its while I negotiated
this is what Mark Wahlberg his team
personally negotiated so they have to do
these reshoots so have to pay him this
they asked Michelle Williams to shoot
she goes whatever you guys want whatever
you want to do they paid her that how in
the world is that on net well factor 2
there's a few things another factor to
who's going to see a Michelle Williams
movie how many people good go and who's
going to see how many people are going
to see a Mark Wahlberg movie what's Mark
Wahlberg's market value vs. Michelle
Williams market value please let me know
let me know who opens a movie okay you
can say whatever the [ __ ] you want but
the marketplace says that Mark Wahlberg
is worth more than Michelle Williams but
but and he's also worth more than Bryan
Callen so this [ __ ] this [ __ ]
about women don't make much as much
money if you can put more butts in the
seat you're gonna get paid I don't wanna
hear this [ __ ] your market value
that what's that stock in mark that's
also men and women and women all
shitload maybe Schumer it makes way more
money and then me as a comic you know
why she can put 15 times more butts in
the seats so she deserves yeah but with
Mark Wahlberg men and women are more
drawn to him than they are Michele
Williams that's nothing to do with
feminism none of that stomach but also
what you gotta take in the count is Mark
Wahlberg is a business
that is he negotiate that he goes
there's gonna be reshoot if you're gonna
try and reshoot here's my [ __ ] rate
otherwise I don't work Michelle Williams
could try and do the same thing but she
hasn't had the same success or that
she'll have to say this - she's not
whereas Mark Wahlberg
you're not worth as much on the mark now
is if it's now if it was Mark Wahlberg
and Angelina Jolie then maybe you have
an argument then correct but do this
you're talking about the 18th and the
c-team yeah and I guarantee Angelina
Jolie makes a fuckload for reshoots this
is such [ __ ] it's more of this this
this sort of like ideological [ __ ] that
comes out of Hollywood it's basically
cultural Marxism I'm [ __ ] should
should the third string quarterback you
paid the same as the starter if she's a
woman yeah obviously how [ __ ] crazy
is that it's not should the WNBA
all-star team get paid the same as the
men's all-star team why they don't fill
the arena there's no demand there that's
the market value that's not because of
males
that's males females that's the
population the United States does not
want to watch females play basketball
they'd rather watch the men it's just
the true whose fault is that right are
we to blame it on the men is it the mark
in the NBA no exactly it's [ __ ] crazy
I'm in so yeah all that's true and I
don't understand the whole me to thing
as well along with it like equal pay for
women now that I think is not even part
of it that she's she's like championing
that thought but I don't think that's
the big part of it the big part of it
was because I guess WME did that
contract for Mark Wahlberg huh behind
her back
they didn't tell her about how about the
response don't tell her so this is what
happened so yeah he they were telling
him or he they're the ones that did the
contract to get the one people they
represent her they represent her
business how much they do tell ya
violation of this is everything the
sacred you're nothing held Michele
Williams what that that's Mark
Wahlberg's business also one more things
so the other thing is according to the
articles it's WME we're not gonna have
wahlberg work with Christopher Plummer
unless he got this money like there was
some weird thing in between mark wasn't
gonna approve of co-starring with
Christopher Plummer unless they get in
the 1.5 million which is weird
I mean Mike Mark Wahlberg's your drawl
so he's gonna have different demands
because he can use it in the world
here's the other thing that so they're
also saying that because you know the
bigger message here is that Kevin Spacey
you know was you know the sexual
misconduct stuff since the their
reshooting this whole movie to get that
guy out of there it's a huge message all
the other actors are like we'll do it
for free and Mark Wahlberg wanted 1.51
but Mark Wahlberg has nothing to do with
Kevin Spacey's meaty movement nothing
yet Mark Wahlberg has a family and bills
to pay and he donate money to the cause
yeah but why would mark oh oh my god
yeah this isn't right Kevin say said
I'll do it for free too or you can pay
me my [ __ ] ray thank you what you're
doing is awful I get that I'll donate to
the cause my time to reshoot this which
I was already had another project I was
doing in another city I'm gonna fly back
and do it for free you're [ __ ] crazy
me so what's how do you guys feel about
him after the public you know backlash
that he just keep donated all that money
to that movement and I think III I don't
I I think that other thing you need to
do it at all I think I think it's just
AI think he got I think what happened
was he got everything else here publicly
shamed into it which is what's going on
now and so people are behaving under
under the auspices of punishment not
being persuaded because the right thing
to do and and I don't think that's good
at all I think it's ridiculous even fun
of by doing it too because you got
publicly shamed yes I know they did ask
it like now you do it after you've been
shame yeah yes why I should have just
like it's not his responsibility to give
you the money to [ __ ] time's up it's
up to it all would be to get it was so
refreshing
if baller came out went hold up and just
kept it I'm keeping this [ __ ] my
agree you know I've busted my balls
since I was a child to get here and now
because of my business savvy and I get
paid for research reshoots cuz I'm such
a good businessman and I'm a draw on
toontown and now I have to succumb to
this [ __ ] I'll donate some money to
it that's fine well I won't or I won't
well I won't because I'm not of I didn't
I didn't do anything I'm not a predator
or I won't because everyone in
Hollywood's not a predator right because
this is
to norm and sexual harassment is not the
same and you know what you guys weren't
attacking online [ __ ] you see that
[ __ ] transformer 17 where it is yes
exactly
that would be refreshing yep yep what's
not good is everyone just bending down
right now bending down oh I'm sorry
you're right I'm sorry I was like it's
not about this with the Woody Allen
stuff like Woody Allen there's been one
one Dylan Farrow I guess I haven't read
it too much on it but I did read a
little bit on it she said that when she
was seven he brought out to an attic
told her to play with like a toy and she
and he fondled her now Mia Farrow and he
had a really bitter divorce and there is
some evidence that Mia Farrow kind of
put that thought into dylan pharaoh's
head I don't know I don't know this this
issue but Woody Allen has a no we don't
have a history at all of molesting
children right they doesn't he just
doesn't not a molester but of younger
dating younger well sure yeah dated
younger women's because he was a he was
a powerful guy and women dated him but
that's not nearly the same as molesting
a seven-year-old all I'm saying is this
it's really interesting cuz there's been
an accusation there there's been one
accusation and that accusation has
caused all these actors to come out and
say I regret working with Woody Allen
and and so he's been indicted he's been
indicted off of an accusation and the
problem with that is the pride you may
believe in accusation like I've always
said they I actually believe the
majority of these women that are talking
about sexual harassment or sexual so I
believe them most of them I don't think
most women to make up stories like that
the problem is if you indict somebody
that's strongly off an accusation you're
next
you are [ __ ] next if that's the
climate you want then anybody can accuse
anybody of anything and bad people will
start to use that as a weapon so you
better be very careful that is why in
this country we've always had innocent
until proven guilty that's a very good
thing to stand by man very good thing to
withhold your judgement until you see
all the evidence and Scarlett Johansson
they're trying to shame her for being in
this movie she goes hold it I don't know
anything about this I don't see any I
haven't seen any evidence I don't know
just
unfair I don't know I just know woody
and I don't there's if you can provide
me with real evidence besides a memory
then I'll say this but you guys are
telling me I should I should indict
somebody and I don't so I think we're
really living in a time where we're one
person with an accusation has a way too
much power it's Barry danger what else
you got Jim in Hawaii there was an
emergency alert that came out okay yeah
yeah so you know we all of those
emergency alerts on our phones if you
you can turn it off whatever but I guess
thousands of people got this emergency
alert about a missile and this is what
it said emergency alert ballistic
missile threat inbound to Hawaii seek
immediate shelter [ __ ] this is not
if you know what would you do it was on
TVs - I know and they said just an
employee there accidentally hit the
wrong button is anyone buying that yeah
they're sticking to that - but hold on
no one has skeptical hippo eyes over
that employees like oh whoops how weird
is that
yeah I don't know the main guy in charge
said yeah there's two buttons and then
the guy during a shift change things got
mixed up and then he hit the wrong
button but it not seems why is that why
is that message fired up - you know like
right why is that even ballistic
missiles right inbound to Hawaii how
serious that is not a drill 38 minutes
until was actually confirmed that there
was no Miss Caroline that means they're
preparing for something does seem like
something happened it really does it
might be the government being like let's
see how we react to it let's see if this
works just in case wow that's scary [ __ ]
man
carry on chin all right that guy Logan
Paul his show is now suspended on
YouTube and all the projects he was
working on were in suspended
indefinitely but they're not closing the
door and tile it's kind of screwed yeah
that's all he's kind of screwed so he's
making something like at least 800,000
dollars just off YouTube a month so then
he had like Pepsi coke or whatever
target they all left them hit all his
serious he's working out they all
dropped them
I gotta give him a timeout yeah that's
why I think it is time cuz he's making
them a crap ton of money too I know
too popular you know I'll probably have
them bounce back huh well that's before
he did that Paula G a while ago just
saying people weren't buying it yeah
let's see this no see it we things back
in six months six months ago clips so
what we came across that day in the
woods was obviously unplanned tenuous
laughs in my judgment and I don't expect
to be forgiven I'm simply here to
apologize so what we came across that
day in the woods was obviously unplanned
and the reactions you saw on tape were
raw they were unfiltered none of us knew
how to react right a few a little bit
try and cry for it I should have never
posted the video I should have put the
cameras down and stopped recording while
we were going through there's a lot of
things I should have done differently
but I didn't and for that from the
bottom of my heart I'm sorry I want to
apologize to anyone who has been
affected or touched by mental illness or
depression or suicide but most
importantly I want to apologize to the
victim and his family for my fans who
are defending my actions
please don't they do not deserve to be
defended like I said I've made a huge
mistake I don't expect to be forgiven
I'm just here to apologize I'm ashamed
of myself I'm disappointed in myself and
I promise to be but that's legit what's
good about it
right it's a good apology but yeah you
just seem kind of like a kind of a
douchebag
I just seems like a tool yeah I forgive
a young man [ __ ] up that's how you
learn best you should eat should he lose
his entire business he built one for you
millions and millions of
seeing anybody get assassinated no I
don't like I think he's a tool yes but
that you know and he'll and he'll the
way you become not a tool the way you
like a young man you do as a young man
you're a [ __ ] idiot I think about
what should i did as a dumb young guy
bones you get older you pay prices here
like end of 2018 he got he got I think
he realized that his actions that you
know that what he did was wrong
sometimes you don't know sometimes it's
just one big joke and then people go hey
hey dude
my brother dot you know all these things
and you go oh [ __ ] I didn't mean it
he's always known for like that shock
factor and [ __ ] around all the times
you get too far what a sketch in one
quick anime one just Robert Whittaker
pulling out he saw this right and there
G we don't know you buckled this it was
a bunch of injuries I don't know if I
hurt no undisclosed yeah that's strange
yeah that your Romero look Rocco if I
dated though yeah I'll take that and
Ramirez been training for somebody else
anyway has me uh he's not he's been
training that one mom she's a
professional
of course well but I mean he's been
training for a fight he's been in camp
is what I mean I don't think so no I
don't know no was gonna fight him I feel
like he was on a card to fight um
Brunson yes
Brunson slight injury yes I think he was
gonna fight Bronson yeah I know they
wanted to fight yeah oh no no no Hughes
suicide branch do bridge oh I know they
were calling each other yeah they were
he's but nothing was confirmed yeah and
now you have Brunson verse Johnson
yeah branch was one to fight you on so
now what happens now so if you're well
if Luke btol is injured interim he's in
trouble it's so gay and and because he's
injured he's got to give the interim
bail pup or they're too interim fo now
there'd be do all no Whitaker's the
actual belt hold yeah
since GSP I'm retired yeah Whitakers
your actual middleweight champion of the
world okay and so this will be for the
in turn belt and then the internal fight
to unify the but yeah I need a piss hard
so forth
what else you got one the next one is
the Turkish Airlines this is oh my god
as it landed it's somehow skidded off
the runway off a cliff and almost into
the Black Sea is that a real picture
though cuz that looks like a giant
that's a real picture here hold I saw it
was actually like an aerial view of it
you see here that is so wild no one was
hurt
look man diary it's really not that far
down you're not dying sir I don't find
it that scary that is frightening that's
it I'm sure the cliff is a lot more
steep when you're actually prior right
it's a giant yeah somehow it stopped
you know that no planes have ever
crashed in the air it's always it's
criminal planes always taking off for
Liam what's this oh that's the inside of
it after crash but it's just people face
down just being loud
panicky obviously baby wailing in the
back yeah so but everyone was fine no
one was injured and their statement said
it had a runway excursion incident
that's it that's as far as they went by
bad we'll get you some free drink
vouchers sure see you see another
Turkish Airlines
oh my bad I'm flying Turkish Airlines
Lynne in August when I go to Kenya I'm
going to see the great migration are you
really yeah with your family oh just my
wife going to a birthday party in Kenya
is it a junior it's interest all the way
it's some time oh my gosh you know
birthday no it's my friend Mars birthday
but they grew up in Kenya so we're gonna
go see the great migration so what you
do is you go and watch the wildebeest
and while you watch the wildebeest they
have to traverse certain bodies of water
and they get young but Ellie also the
only thought crocodiles and also also
the Lions just wait and they'll just
watch him pass and jump on one and you
can be right there or or more likely you
just gonna be watching wildebeest all
day that is a possibility say look at me
that's a sir that's a possibility but I
know you just kind of pitch this out
yeah and it's gonna be yep I know a lot
of people misunderstand
please understand or you need to have
your watch and will would be with all
day with real canyons and they will show
us the secret areas let's say doing
birthday so my my he said hey Brennan
nurse $10,000 in Kenya fly hearing yeah
that I would not go my my what's her
name so Antonella who is grew up in
Kenya she will take you on a walk
through you know the reserve you have to
get shots right yeah Adam oh I grew up
all over them I grew up I know but you
have to do it again my body is 100%
ready for everything but anyway
definitely not but I went there and she
said she said I said yeah but if you
even go near the water the crocodiles
would common shoes that's not true at
all I've been swimming plenty of times
where they're crocodiles I was like no
you haven't
she goes yeah you just have to know
where they are and uh no no she's not
she said um cuz I was all boat down
there and then she said um you know
sometimes I you know you'll see Lions
not worried about that so her husband
told me he's from Norway said we were
walking and the Lions are there she goes
don't worry no it's fine keep walking
then you see like you know [ __ ] a
leopard no no no for real
and then she goes but if I tell you to
climb a tree to climb a tree okay and he
goes okay then they saw a water buffalo
and she goes climb a tree right not
climb a tree right now climb a tree
right now
well I climb David durometer tree that's
the one you want to worry about what
water buffalo not the Lyonnaise uh have
you seen when the mouse I'm pretty
worried if you just see a pack of lions
when have you seen when the Masai the
Masai go and just decide you know they
hunt some eyes when they're hungry
they'll go take a Lions kill you ever
seen that oh yeah where they just go
stand up and walk toward up and then
I'll run away King sir that's gangster
[ __ ] that's gangster [ __ ] hopefully
don't get [ __ ] weird disease in
Africa not me I've been there twice I
know he's supposed justiça in LA bro
yeah rich it's all really I do but I'm a
man look at that water buffaloes are
pretty gnarly yeah when you shoot him
and they go into the tall grass you
gotta go after them and they're waiting
for you that's when you get killed
pretty cool animal it's a cool animal
very sturdy animal yes bear started yeah
thick skin
yeah it's hard to take down can take a
big round in the old chest too and kinda
keep coming yeah it takes a while here
we'll hear it good yeah that's a nice
you get chin 13 I can't believe go to
Africa at your age yeah I know but I'm
going Africa the right way I'm doing the
right way yeah I'm doing a serious silly
right way would be go with campaigns and
hunt lions but like I'm kind of doing
that I mean I'm not saying but I'm hey
no I'm not no no I know I know you want
pictures of the fans you know what's
gonna happen
Brian you're gonna fly down there this
Kenyan lady is gonna show you don't do
it off they don't do air quotes hey get
it show you not doing quotes about her
you're gonna watch the wildebeest walk
now I all day camping you know the
wilderness sitting you back on a plane
for 20 I'll be in a tent in a wilderness
now well I have servants yes now here's
the thing will it be cooking for me yes
well it'd be a first classic that's
right yes no no servants can be all
colors now not an Africa sir maybe
you're right they'll be taller they will
be my side all right fine I shouldn't
call them servants the trees they'll
have staff yeah I'll buy stuff I mean
just black stuff I'll have people who do
everything I tell them now if they're
black fine if they're white I'm an
equal-opportunity
[ __ ] either way I'll be paid you know
you should do more tea please is that
demand white servants where am I [ __ ]
where's my [ __ ] unbroken sons too hot
on my face
Wow demand white servants when you know
yes see how that goes whatever your name
is
Duan eh all right where's my umbrella
anything else - uh yeah white hunter
black heart did you watch it huh
white hunter black heart they used to
say did you watch the Viking Saints game
sure did sure did
well this is all the talk of it a guy
Stefon Diggs made this unbelievable
catch you know we're supposed to lose
the game yeah and then Marcus Williams
did a terrible
blocker hit missed him actually took out
his teammate yeah and then cost him the
game correct do you see that guy making
up
mean how do you [ __ ] up that bad is so
weird it's just those words worst like
what's the heat of what's crazy the guys
are amazing player I think how much
money that man gets paid three seconds
that deep drop so much way this man gets
played just just make the tackle game's
over just make the tackle oh my god
that's football it's best oh my god so
now you got the Eagles Vikings and you
got Pats jacks I want to just do a
little left turn on sports and I want to
talk to you about do who kim koo kachoo
his name - whoo - ho Choi do ho try it
yeah uh as awesome as he is I feel like
even at forty five when he fights a guy
like Jeremy Stephens Jeremy Stephens is
just stronger more powerful heavier no
disagree no uh actually
Kim's actually bigger than Germany
Stephen I don't think so his body looks
sama he's bigger but he looks weaker he
doesn't look as strong like he doesn't
look as such that's just Stephen that's
more power more power you so fight at 55
right remember before we start the
conversation you thought he was they
were fighting at 50 I know this is it's
that's 40 even though it's part of 55
but here's my question
what is your like so how old is do joy
he's only 24 how he's an awesome when
he's not that young
so what is your prediction of his fuse
will remember 45 he's he's 510 so he's a
Baek 45 yeah he's never gonna be a world
he's never gonna be world champ he's not
he always put that was my question it's
like it's not gonna be he's not gonna be
world champion and chin where the [ __ ]
are my voodoo doughnuts I'd said second
round TKO Jimmy Stevens that's exactly
what happens so finding my voodoo
doughnuts I need a dozen chocolate glaze
for me and my old friend here don't say
old friend don't you or do you want to
twist no I want to [ __ ] I want a
chocolate glaze default if you bring you
thing but chocolate glaze we're gonna
bust are you guys good this week or next
week this week this was I'm still sick
so there's no diet all right this onion
isn't funny your diet is an excuse to
just be eat like a fat kid dude
that was
you know yeah I feel like that's what
you answered my question I feel like
he's got he's got as great as he is he's
got physical limitations I feel like
certain guys are just too powerful for
him even in 45 in the fort but it's not
that has nothing to do that it's his
fighting style he he's actually more of
a technical strike than I know that they
looked like that but it still didn't
stop Stevens and so I would choose well
what do you mean fight that way like
well Jeremy Stephens has more power than
max Holloway okay so but what do you
mean but Matt's always the world yeah
but what do you mean fights that way so
how would he change his fighting so he
does know brawl that's what he that's
his style
right he loves to make it exciting fight
right and he had an opera so he had
fight of the year against yeah cousin
yeah no else Watson does it knock people
out like that right so he would have to
do he'd have to change his face out on
the outside yeah but that's how he
fights man you know the [ __ ] question
no because you'd have to make that
change if you want to not lose that's
you know as great as he is he's still
losing to these guys so how do you you
can't if you breathe brawling is not
working against dudes like that you got
to change your style you have to siding
fire depends what you want to do yeah do
you feel as if I know it was going in
the way of Steven's side regardless but
did you feel as if it was stopped a
little early no no he covered up - I'll
tell you did impress masseuse masseuse
Minh he just held right he was he lost
so much hype and then the not only was
his performance bad he played it super
safe why even going to training camp if
you're just gonna wrestle for three
rounds why even have a camp why worked
on any other skills if you're just in
wrestling maybe he just doesn't have a
confidence in striking because it
definitely does he just didn't feel like
it and then whatever but then the thing
that royally [ __ ] him is his
post-fight speech that's 30% I give you
guys 30 percent and Dana was like that
fight was [ __ ]
that's 30 percent what do you give us
when we put it on pay-per-view 60 he was
I thought that was awful I have no idea
what we're gonna do with him next he
said I'm the best Walter way in the
world and like not really man
I think he's so overhyped he you could
almost no say that with that kind of
pressure it's a little bit
looked a little bit like you know what
I'm going to say the khabib fight with
with yeah in other words like he he'll
he'll wear you like a backpack and where
he's now I mean it worked against Maddie
but that could be is gonna destroy you
on the ground yeah he's passing he stole
the elbows punches who's been just held
yeah he just held he didn't not did he
did and a striking look amateur is just
I don't know man I don't they calls out
Kobe come to nice probably his best
matchup two wrestlers and Kobe's not
exactly the best striker but enjoy a guy
like tier until if you think yeah that's
good or any of those top guys who aren't
gonna play these you know these games
with you are boy meal who was gonna be
on the show day we couldn't get her to
later our boy Emil meek freaking you
know he just he started training at 21
so but now I thought you look good
hey dude sturdy son of a [ __ ] but I'll
tell you what no one's lost more stock
yet from a wind than Huisman I thought
man did not go well for him only great
night of fights now I really page look
terrible I'll she broke her office was
tough but she didn't look great
yeah you know the fights weren't great
what can you do that it chin you want
anymore you good I'm good man all right
count them where you gonna be buddy glad
you asked buddy you come out and see me
in Columbus at the funny bone
January 25 26 27 and then Washington DC
the party keeps on [ __ ] going we got
February 1 2 & 3 I'm at the DC improv I
think it's almost sold out from what I
heard I got a look at tickets bounce and
get your goddang tickets how about you
I'm in Boston this week that is sold out
next show is this January 31st Denver
very first is sold out so we added a
Wednesday night that is January 31st
Comedy Works downtown Denver get your
tickets right now and then the second
and the third of February I'm in st.
Louis get your tickets now st. Louis T
fat cake on for Brian and myself also
tomorrow
we're releasing the road dog tease I saw
them on the road but now they're
available at TIFF at kake.com
Mero dog get your Road dog tease
tomorrow 5:00 p.m. Pacific t5k calm this
is the final kid we're out